your eyes are really hard to work with
mom Courtney Cox received a quarantine
Glam sesh from her teenage daughter Koko
on Sunday the 55 year old actress took
to Instagram to show off the 15
year-olds work which includes her
signature winged eyeliner
Courtney revealed the finished product
where you can see Coco added a teardrop
in a smiley face under her mom's eyes
Courtney caption the video quote ix Koko
to do my makeup I guess you get what you
pay for
during quarantine the talented mother
and daughter duo have been showing off
their skills in this video
Courtney took to the piano and Coco to
the mic to cover burn from Hamilton
[Music]
earlier this month Courtney faced one of
her toughest interviews yet which was
conducted by none other than Coco hi I'm
Courtney Cox this is my daughter Coco in
honor of the second season of Courtney's
Facebook watch series nine months with
Courtney Cox Coco was tasked with
grilling her mom about pregnancy and
Parenthood described as a child
absolutely adorable curious incredible
sense of humor and porky you're annoying
courtney shares cocoa with her
ex-husband David Arquette who recently
gushed she eats he about how quote
incredible his daughter is she's
incredible she's got more talent than I
ever had or ever could ed confidence
which is really amazing
[Music]